just total irresponsibility why won't
the Biden Administration do something
about this well because the Biden
Administration is is directing its
Federal resources toward much more
pressing issues like terrorizing parents
who don't want their kids to get trans
and terrorizing pro-lifers and
infiltrating Catholic masses and trying
to harass Christians for going to church
on Sunday Josh Hawley grilled the
Attorney General Merrick Garland just
yesterday on on that ladder
FBI initiative to infiltrate churches
such as my own churches where Catholics
just want to go on Sundays and worship
God in a traditional way that has
existed for at least 1200 years
I notice a pattern though
the FBI field office in Richmond on the
23rd of January of this year issued a
memorandum in which they advocated for
and I quote the exploration of new
avenues for tripwire and Source
development against traditionalist
Catholics it's their language including
those who favor the Latin Mass
attorney general are you cultivating
sources and spies in Latin Mass parishes
and other Catholic parishes around the
country the justice department does not
do that it does not um do investigations
based on religion I saw the document you
said appalling it's appalling I'm in
complete agreement with you I understand
that the FBI has withdrawn it and it's
now looking into how this could ever
have happened how did it happen that's
what they're looking into how many
informants do you have in Catholic
churches Across America I don't know and
I don't believe we have any informants
aimed at Catholic churches there it is
so Merit Garland he's a very talented
politician he's been in the upper
echelons of Washington for a long time
and he gives the right answer to Holly
and let's say he's being
sincere I was appalled Senator Hawley I
can't believe this was happening I've
ordered them not to do it anymore I was
totally appalled
okay that's good
but then did you notice that that second
answer that that Garland gave Holly says
before we go how many informants do you
have in the Catholic churches in Garland
makes a big mistake he says I don't know
oops uh I mean I don't think we have any
wait hold on you just said I don't know
implying that you've you've got some you
just don't know what the number is
implying that your first answer
was kind of disingenuous right
I was appalled I can't believe that the
FBI is going in there and harassing
these Catholics I'm going to get to the
bottom of this how exactly I'm not going
to tell you but I'm I'm absolutely
infuriated okay well just all right
before we get to any of that you know do
what you can but how many people do you
have spying on the Catholics oh I don't
know
I mean none yeah okay okay so Hawley is
is grilling Garland and then
we get Senator Cruz
I don't say it just because he's a
friend of mine I don't say it just
because we hosted a podcast for three
years together
this guy is just the best at grilling
Witnesses in the Senate there is nobody
better than Cruz so Cruz goes in he's
going after Garland and he brings up the
case of Mark Houck a pro-life activist
who was threatened with jail time the
doj showed up at his house with his kids
terrorized and arrested him all for
pushing back on a pro-abortion fanatic
who was screaming at his son often just
like hey get away from my son you got
the men in the windbreakers showing up
the federales show up to your door and
arrest you and threaten you Cruz says
what gives
sidewalk count
devote resources to count P to to
prosecute people who are violently
firebombing Crisis Pregnancy it is a
priority of the department to prosecute
and investigate and find the people who
are doing those firebombings they are
doing it at night and in secret so and
we have found we have found one group
which we did prosecute we found one how
many have there been how many attacks
there have been a lot and if you have
any information specifically as to who
those people are we ask yourself
authorized 20 agents going to Mr houck's
house and he offered to turn himself in
through Council but you didn't want that
the Department of Justice wanted to make
a show of it did you personally
authorize it and do you want to
apologize to Mr Mrs Houck and her seven
children for being terrorized decisions
about how to do that are made at the
level of the FBI agents on scene
so there we go it's the same kind of
answer from garland that we saw when he
was answering Holly says I I don't know
I didn't make these decisions this was
not me this was lower level FBI agents I
don't we're looking into it I'm very
very responsible Senator Cruz how dare
you impugn my motives or my integrity
and okay that's fine but then Cruz he
also he's just kind of gets in there I
remember once he was grilling Mark
Zuckerberg at Facebook and what Cruz
really shines in is he he's doing the
grilling and he's he's asking all these
questions over here over here with this
hand over here and then he just hits you
with the other hand right when you're
not expecting it so he's grilling Mark
Zuckerberg on whatever I don't remember
and then out of nowhere he goes why was
Palmer lucky fired
because there was a rumor that a major
Facebook executive had been fired for
being a conservative and he just off
footed him and Zuckerberg didn't know
what to say because he was so focused on
this other topic so we saw Crews do this
again
Cruz is grilling Garland on all sorts of
issues and then he says hey one quick
question just before you go
is it illegal to protest on the grounds
of a judge's house while a case is
pending here's the answer
General Garland
is it a federal crime to protest outside
of a judge's home with the intent of
influencing that judge as to a pending
case the answer to that is yes but I
also want to at least respond to your
characterization of the department which
I vigorously disagree with uh oh what uh
yes the thing you said is true but let
me get off this for a second because
what Cruz was doing there was quoting
the U.S code verbatim which says that
the protests that we saw after the Dobbs
decision was leaked all the pro-abortion
fanaticates who showed up to alito's
house who showed up to Kavanaugh's house
who showed up to the homes of the
conservative justices to protest
terrorize them terrorize their kids in
the middle of the night one guy showed
up to assassinate Brett Kavanaugh and
the local police and the federal police
just allowed this to happen it was
completely illegal
and so now Garland's answer to Holly and
The Crucible I didn't know I wasn't
aware we're investigating we're looking
into it had I known we would have done
things differently it's exposed as
complete BS
because Garland says yes
what they did was illegal
I know it was illegal I know it was
happening it was all over the news and
I'd let it happen I'm the Attorney
General of the United States and I
permitted this kind of lawlessness
when it benefited my political party
I brought down the full force of the
federal government to terrorize a
pro-lifer and his wife and his kids for
having the temerity to protest outside
of or not even to protest outside to to
pray outside and to peacefully
demonstrate outside of an abortion
clinic oh yeah we're going to terrorize
those people
but when
left Wingers violate federal law
outside the homes of Supreme Court
Justices one of whom goes and tries to
kill the guy
that I knowingly allowed to happen
absolutely humiliating day for Merrick
Garland on Capitol Hill great job to
those Senate Republicans the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member of dailywear.com
use code Knowles at checkout
you get two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]